Good morning, guys.
I've been sick for the past few days,
so I haven't been on here in a minute.
But today I was in the mood for some Japanese breakfast,
so that's what I'm making right now.
Okay, so let's plate it up.
I have some miso soup over here.
I'm gonna show you guys.
I love a good miso soup.
I don't have tofu,
so it's without tofu.
This is our miso soup.
Let's plate up all the other stuff.
So I made some salmon.
Let's do that next. I have some salmon,
a charred miso salmon.
I also made some rice.
I've been up since the crack of dawn,
so I'm so excited to have some breakfast.
Right now we have our rice and salmon,
and then I made some side dishes.
The first side dish is gonna be some edamame that I'm just gonna salt.
I've got some smoky sea salt,
so that's done.
And then I also just sauteed some spinach
with some sesame oil and sesame seeds.
This is our spinach.
Oh, I made some pickled cucumber salad,
so I'm gonna do that next.
This is one of my favorite little sides that I make.
I have it quite a lot,
and I always make it a little different.
Okay, I think we're ready to eat this,
our little Japanese inspired breakfast spread.
I'm so excited right now.
So excited to try the salmon.
Seaweed and the miso soup is always my favorite thing.
Mm hmm. Oh,
I forgot. I also made myself a cup of fennel tea.
I've been really liking fennel tea lately,
so that's what I've been having.
But I'm gonna sit down and have some breakfast now.